Let's say you are socially anxious.
Ok so what happens if you are socially anxious?
You go to a party, your heart starts beating faster.
Why?
The party is a monster. Why?
Because it rated you.
And it judges you, it places you low below the dominance hierarchy.
Because that is a negative judgment.
And that disrupts your sexual success.
And that means that you are being evaluated in part by nature itself.
That's right, so you're not confronting the Chaos dragon when you're in a social situation.
So what do you do?
You do this, you bend over.
And that radiates low dominance, I am not a danger.
You won't get far with that.
But that is the most logical thing to do, as opposed to a tyrant
"I am not a danger"
You look at the king and you are dead
I am not a danger, I lean forward.
And then what happens inside
"What do people think of me? What do people think about me?"
"Do I look stupid?"
"I look stupid, dear, I'm weird, I hate it here, man I'm sweating too much."
It is all internalized. It is all self-focus.
The eye is not working.
What do you tell these people
do NOT stop thinking about yourself, because that will not work.
Just like, do NOT think of a white elephant.
White elephant, white elephant, white elephant
You can't tell people not to think about anything, because then they end up in a loop.
What you do with socially anxious people is you say
Look at other people
Look at them
Right. Why?
Because if you look at them you can see what they think.
And, unless you are very poorly socialized, and some people are, some people don't have social skills and so
The reason they can't go to a party is because they don't know how to introduce themselves.
No one has ever explained to them how to behave.
And so they are a good
candidate for behavioral therapy. Because you can let them walk through the process how you actually do
express the procedures necessary for social acceptance.
But most people are not like that, they can.
So if they are very introverted and high in neuroticism
Then they can talk pretty well with someone one on one.
Why?
Because you look at them!
When I look at you
That's something you can do if you have to talk to a group of people
NEVER talk to the GROUP of people.
That does not exist
You talk to individuals.
And they reflect the entire group for you
Because they are all taken away
So you look at one person
They radiate what everyone thinks. And you know how to talk to one person.
So that's easy
So
As soon as you focus on the person and not on yourself
Push your attention outside, use your eyes to push your attention outside.
And you start paying attention, well then all automatic mechanisms start working
And then you stop acting weird. Because when we talk, and I look here-
I don't know what you're going to do
And I place disturbances in -
They are bad agreements in our
In our conversation. And the reason is, I don't pay attention.
So that's why the eye is at the top of the pyramid.
What makes it possible to win all sets in the dominance hierarchy is the eye. Pay attention!
Pay attention.
That's the point
That is why the Egyptians worshiped Horus
That's why Horus was the one who saved Osiris from the deep.
It is the capacity to watch out for
What attracts your attention the most?
* KLAP *
What your right hemisphere indicates as abnormal.
It attracts your attention.
This is not going very well.
I don't have to look at that.
WRONG!
You have to look at that!
Which is not going well, because that-
That is the terrible monster that you may eat, but it is also the place where you get all the information.
So
That is why it is useful to have discussions with your enemies
Because they tell you things you don't know yet
And that's such a good thing, because if you don't know that
Then you're not that smart, are you?
There may come a time when you had to know that
And maybe your enemies tell you why you're so stupid
And maybe some other things that aren't true
But
Even if it's one thing that's right, man, thank you, maybe I can still work on that
And, then I no longer have to carry that with me
So, that is partly the reason why the predator
It is always the predator that has the gold.
It is the person who has a message that you would rather not hear.
So it's hard, it's hard. But that doesn't matter, life is hard